if there's one thing that 2020 taught us
it's that any time a large group of
popular twitch streamers jump into the
same server together
funny [ __ ] or drama is bound to happen
and with rust twitch's latest game
obsession it's no different
an offline tv server featuring the likes
of valkyrie pokeman
ludwig shroud myth and everybody's
favorite
madman xqc what could go wrong
well from alleged ddos attacks to xqc
talking mad
[ __ ] to stream sniping allegations to
multiple streamers quitting the server
entirely apparently everything
[Music]
all right guys new year same deal we're
on our way to 2 million subscribers but
we can't do it without your help so
scroll down and hit that subscribe
button and let's start off 2021 on the
right foot
so this otb rust server was hosted by
streamer and talent manager bobo ape
and it was meant to be an ongoing thing
a place where twitch streamers could
jump in
and collaborate and make content
together now check out the lineup that
was put together for this debut stream
it's actually nuts disguise toast
pokemane
ludwig jacksepticeye shroud sodapoppin
and of course everyone's favorite madman
no
poke yeah no [ __ ] get out talking about
move move
except the 50 streamer server that was
supposed to go live on december 26th
it well didn't multiple streamers either
couldn't connect or were experiencing
consistent crashes and
eventually the debut stream was delayed
to the next day
some people speculated that the server
crashed due to the amount of random
viewers trying to get on
but some of the streamers involved said
that they thought it was a series of
ddos attacks that
caused the problems and ape eventually
tweeted out that the server would go
live the following
day and of course xqc's notorious
reputation
followed him onto the server the server
is gonna implode
soon i can just feel it i'm predicting
now that xqc is making a base i'm
predicting he's making a base they're
gonna gather up
and they're gonna start freaking people
out and once that happens
either the server dies or he gets kicked
that's what i think is gonna happen but
okay before i break down the
laundry list of xqc filled drama
let me explain what the hell rust is
rust drops you into a world naked as all
hell
and the whole point is to stay alive
craft resources
and try not to get killed by other
players on the server
and if you die you lose everything and
have to start from scratch
now generally there's two ways to play
rust there's the raiding pvp
element where players attack forts and
murder each other for
loot but there's also a more passive
role playing style where you just want
to survive
craft cool [ __ ] with your friends and
only fight if you have to
okay getting back to the offline tv
server it launched a day later on
december 27th
and pretty quickly there were problems
now the first piece of news to come from
this was when valkyrie who's a big
reason
why this collaboration was happening in
the first place abruptly ended her
stream
are you trying to you're trying to take
my eyes away from the situation
is that what's going on
at the time of publication we still
don't totally know why she ended her
stream
but a toxic chat is high on the list of
possibilities
now onto xqc we've covered his antics
before and it's
no different here over the course of a
few days xqc's fans managed to start
[ __ ] with andy milinakis he also landed
in hot water after he was toxic to
another streamer on the server
by the name of ash but don't worry
ash fired back be useful for once put
some wood in the fireplace
you've gone back so don't be a pink
piece of [ __ ]
don't be kind for once yeah xqc then
quickly apologized on twitter in a very
xqc-like way
and i wish that was the end of the drama
but no because on january 1st
new year's goddamn day pokeman announced
she quit the server because
she wasn't having fun anymore i'm just
not gonna
get back on because i'm not having a
good time
i just don't have really like the band
with her energy to like
spend two hours getting stuff and then
lose it all and have it despawn and then
die to radiation as i'm trying to do
now to be very clear she never points
directly at xqc as the source of her
lack of
fun it's just totally a coincidence that
she quit
when she did after pokeman quit bobo ape
who you'll remember as the guy who
started the server
announced that a new server was on the
way focusing on a more
passive role-playing style he also noted
that this new server was in no way
related to
xqc's decision to murder everybody he
came into contact with
and that the old server would still be
available for those people who wanted to
pvp
now this rabbit hole goes even deeper
because the same day that pokeman quit
the server
xqc accused edison parks who's a
streamer that was playing with tsm myth
of stream sniping he actually was
she was he went out of the seat and uh
that's just shameless dude i can't
that's just [ __ ] shameless that's so
cringe dude
and then shroudy rowdy who's been
critical of xqc for allegedly stream
sniping in the past
called him out for being hypocritical
xqc should
really keep that stuff to himself
calling people out for a stream sniping
ain't cool man
unless you know for a fact they're doing
it as in pulling up a stream on their
stream
then sure call him out he's playing a
dangerous game
what followed xqc's allegations is a
bunch of finger pointing between xqc
myth and edison parks they all accused
each other of stream sniping
and honestly it's some pretty funny
childish nonsense
in the end though edison parks took to
twitter to
apologize and explain his side of the
story i'm both
surprised at how drama-filled this
server is
but also it's xqc it's exactly what
we've come to expect from him
sure being upset when the inevitable
happens is fine
but also you invited a guy to the server
whose whole brand is mayhem
you can't get mad at him when he creates
it it's like getting pissed off when ice
melts
it's going to happen and you can't just
not include him
xqc is insanely popular and like i've
said time and time again
people love watching chaos unfold in
real time
so while it's probably extremely
frustrating to get murdered consistently
when you only want to run around naked
in the forest
thousands of people are tuning into
these streams because
of xqc's antics and guaranteed
we have not seen the last of it if i was
playing this game if you dropped me into
rust on a 50 person server
yeah i would probably play the xqc role
it'd be a [ __ ] disaster
i would just be i'd be such a [ __ ]
considering my history with cs go and
team killing you know
right now
oh no but also you invited a guy to the
server whose whole brand
is
hello yo devon what's going on buddy
it's colton it's been way too long i'm
excited to be back on don't have me this
weekend
wait what devin
okay i can't hang up the phone oh my god